so it's our own fault like that's why I
say it starts with the women I don't
because and like and on top of that like
it's the development of birth control I
feel like the development yeah
you're right I would say if I was to put
it on men I would say it's because men
did all that meant men are the ones who
who made those laws even men are the
ones who came up with no fault divorce
men are the ones who come up with so you
know I can't just
I know I know it's popular to kind of
put it all on
one gender
um and I think that you know there's
there there's both the fault but if I
look at it ultimately you know men men
have played a massive role I'm not
saying every single man of course not
right but men in general have played a a
massive role in this oftentimes by not
stepping into their proper masculine
roles and leaving it for
women to pick up the what do you think
can you explain that more what I mean is
you know if I get a woman pregnant right
okay and
I can step up and do what I'm supposed
to do morally ethically
family socially cultural like I'm I'm
supposed to step up into that right and
and I and I choose not to I choose to
abandon I choose to leave her to fend
for herself and deal with that or what
maybe maybe I'm sending a check every
you know right then
that's that's my bet and by the way and
this is and this is happening to the
tune of millions right right and I I
agree with you but I'm sure you're so
familiar with the red pill you know
women women are the ones that leave we
leave 70 to 80 of the time ninety
percent of our college education so so
like while while there are two sides to
it like and we we could talk about the
30 like there wouldn't you start with
the 70 what women are the ones I think I
think we're talking about two different
situations right so we're talking well
you you just so so the male abandonment
tends to happen at a relatively early
stage uh-huh right so the child is born
and the child is not even born yet and
the dude disappears slips out the
picture and then and then you're talking
about there's actually a relationship or
a marriage and then the woman breaks
away from that yeah both I I would say
women leave relationships more too and
in the first situation like we know when
we're ovulating so I just feel like if
we're in control of birth like that's on
us and and a lot of times girls will
like try to make a guy that's not a
husband into a husband and they'll
they'll try to like get pregnant and
keep the kid like and so so it's like
I'm not gonna put that on the men when
you knew who he was yeah I put it on
both okay okay I put it on both I'm not
going to let men off the hook here right
just like I don't I wouldn't let women
off the hook if someone was trying to
put this all on men I'd be like no no
you can't let women off the hook it's
also someone's trying to put it all on
on on a woman I'm like well you can't
let men off the hook right there's
millions and millions of men out there
who are not doing what they're supposed
to be doing
as a single parent
I think that
I know he's saying that many invented
the pill
but somebody must have invented cyanide
or poison nobody made them take it right
so just because somebody's making
something
it that means that oh you can go ahead
and take it and when it comes to single
parents
you can understand you saying
I've only got one child single parent
one child
but when you get women having free four
five six seven children eight I think
there's some out there nine that was
still looking for dates sometimes by
nine different fathers can't put it all
on demand I'll say yeah the first one
yeah because
a lot of men
don't ask to be fathers
they don't ask to be fathers my son's
dad never asked to be a father actually
I was on the pill it was an accident I
actually discussed it with him
and even though he agreed that I have
the child
I was
I knew that if I had to raise him on my
own I did because he never asked for him
and I don't believe in abortion
so as far as I'm concerned
single parent says no excuse even if the
father's not there there's plenty of
really good Role Models out there male
role models you know you've got the
grandfathers you've got the uncles
you've got the really good friends
and then you should be able to do that
with a child without expecting anything
my son is 36 years old I think in all
his life I took 100 pounds from his dad
that's what I asked for 100 pound for
his dad
and when they say that oh the government
supports him and everything and I
remember at the time I was studying and
they said oh you know you get extra
money for being a single parent but they
want to know who the dad is and I said
nope take your money
take your money it's not a good
influence so my son take your money I'll
do it on my own but he always had good
Role Models yes and that's important and
that's important too many they make too
many single parents make it look so hard
you know it's hard when you don't keep
on it's hard when you don't have to shut
your legs when you don't know how to
shut your legs and you don't know how to
get birth control of course it's going
to be hard now bearing in mind there's
no excuses I'm the exception to every
rule there is out there I'm the
exception
any situation I can say I'm the
exception to everything so I'm a rarity
but I know a lot of single parents and
either for that was some of them that
friends of mine because I was a
hard-working person I can afford for
them to have children and they're not
working but I couldn't afford for me to
have any more yes because I was hard
working so I can't even say put it on
the men because at the end of the day
yeah you can say put a condom you think
that after getting pregnant on the pill
that I just relied on the pill I just
rely on the condom I was using
everything there was you name it even if
I had the injection and they said it's
90 I'm still using a condom even if I
was on the pill I'm still using a condom
so it's got to be down to the women yeah
because at the end of the day
a single parent with more than one child
for the same person I can understand
that but a single parent with loads of
little
I was gonna say little nigglets
that's just a saying that in my head
yeah what was it it's not news yeah
but the little babies yeah and you've
got loads of them running around I
remember I grew up with a girl and and
she was like the black version of
Angelina Jolie I saw her and every
single nationality you see she slept
with maybe to try them out
you know and they were oh she never had
two kids that resembled each other and
they were all hers so she didn't yeah at
the end of the day and you're saying
that
I'm playing deva's advocate here because
I've got one child for my son's dad yes
guess how many children he's got my
son's a second now the third guess how
many how many he he's got the father of
your child
oh boy I mean I don't know sixteen
sixteen okay wow 16. I was gonna say
eight
[Music]
so you're trying to tell me that all
right then the first one I think he was
at school and it was a school like there
was a school the second one was supposed
to be my son but I knew I knew different
I knew there was another one out there
that's why I said third because he's
still trying to convince us it's a
second okay
all of his children know their parents
all of his children know their dad
you're just trying to tell me that
you've got
you see a man and he's got two children
a different parent three children
how the hell are you gonna get to the
woman who's at number 16. then he got
married to somebody don't have no
children for him
but you see I mean so you can't keep on
sometimes the women shut your legs it's
both I mean it takes shut your legs
because the women that go out there and
they will see a man and they think oh
he's this and this but the difference is
it's 80 90 well it's like it's most
women where it's a small percentage of
men yeah and so you're going to say what
percentage of men that want sorry that
it's a small percentage of men that
women want and so that are doing that's
what I'm saying like it's such a small
percentage So when you say it's it's the
men too it's like yeah okay it's 5 10
whatever it is and then when you get the
children I can't see that I'm not sure I
get what's being argued against here no
who's to blame for like you know single
parents you know it's all sometimes they
say it's all about the women so is it
about the man to me to me and I think
sometimes the single parents they they
yeah those women use it they use the
sympathy yeah to me it's to me it's
completely 50 50. like it's literally to
me it's to me it's literally 50. I don't
think it's 50 50. as a single parent I
don't think it's 50 50. I don't I mean
if I go out there and I father 16 kids
I don't know why I would be absolved
yeah of the fact that I've chosen to go
out there we have more control like we
can be out we you can get an IUD it's 99
effective you don't have that control
we do we do to us pretty strong extent
it's not like the women like when they
get pregnant like if you want like I'm
not saying like like some you know I
mean if if I wanted to have 16 kids I
could have 16 kids
why are women choosing to have 16 Shoes
all right then some of them have got
five children I could even just be just
like if I were a snake I could even be
completely deceptive about it like oh
I've got 14 no he wasn't I'm saying you
could as a man yeah as a kid you could I
could have you could have 12 kids out
there and go and have a 13th with
another she's not even aware about the
of the other 12 or whatever you can say
oh whatever you know even promise oh you
know we're gonna we're gonna do this one
dude there's some dudes in this
situation they were all aware no even
girls girl they know and this is what
irritates me is they'll they'll act like
they don't know they might not know that
like maybe 13 kids they might not know
but you know what a dude is sleeping
around you do and I don't believe it for
a second when these girls say oh I
didn't know the difference between
sleeping around and fathering or just
having a ton of kids I mean to me it's
to me it's a 50 50 thing some of them I
mean
I'm with you there what do you think um
because and what makes it worse is that
they choose the bad men and then they're
proud of it at the time and then when it
doesn't work they blame the men you know
either woman come up to me
Woolworths isn't there anymore but she
came up to me with a baby and said he's
got a boy now
say he's and I thought you already had
two girls
you're not with him
and you're gonna approach me to say that
he's got a son because I I'm the only
one with one and I thought to myself why
would you do that why would you even go
there and have more children
you know but all that all the women knew
all the women knew that he had all these
children they always they always know as
many of you know I was just banned on
take talk and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible